another round of budget talks between
congressional Democrats in the White
House seems to have led nowhere with the
US government shutdown entering its
third week the sticking point is funding
for Donald Trump's border wall and with
Democrats reviving talk of impeachment
the US president is now threatening to
take radical action have you considered
using emergency powers to grant yourself
authorities to build this wall without
congressional approval and second guess
I have to go you have yes I have and I
can do it if I want so you don't need
congressional approval to build no we
can use them absolutely we can call a
national emergency because of the
security of our country absolutely no we
can do it I haven't done it I may do it
I may do it
Trump did indicate after the meeting
when he spoke that he would actually
consider calling a national emergency in
order to construct his wall so that he
could do so without the approval of
Congress Trump also summarized the
meeting he felt the meeting was
productive but the representatives seem
to have the other idea we had a very
very productive meeting lengthy and
sometimes contentious it's very hard to
see how progress will be made unless
they open up the government we
recognized on the Democratic side that
we really cannot resolve this until we
open up government he said he'd keep the
government closed for a very long period
of time months or even years Trump also
said that in the meeting Nancy Pelosi
the Speaker of the House of
Representatives that she told Donald
Trump that she had no interest in
impeachment they were not looking for
impeachment that's the quote there has
been a call to get the ball rolling and
kind of jump start impeachment
proceedings against Trump from some
Democrats one Democrat in the House of
Representatives actually used some
rather colorful language to make this
call
bullies don't win baby they talk because
we're gonna go in there win impeach the
mother while Trump said that he was told
by Nancy Pelosi that quote were not
looking for impeachment in the meeting
that just happened Nancy Pelosi has
elsewhere said that she would be open to
the impeachment of US President Trump
we shouldn't be impeaching for a
political
and we shouldn't avoid impeachment for
political reasons we've reached this
point where if you have control of
Congress or half of Congress and the
president is from the other party you
attack the president by refusing to
provide the votes to pass the
president's agenda he'd run into
problems right away because there is no
national emergency is causing this this
impasse over something that most
Americans don't really want or care
about I think that the upper hand goes
to the Democrats and they're just gonna
wait him out until his own party tells
him he has to fund the government
because it's costing the their
supporters too much and it's costing the
country too much to hold 1/4 of the
government unfunded for a lengthy period
of time is going to cause so much pain
that he's going to have to cave
you